recent vaccine trial results have
been caused for optimism that we can
combat the cobit 19 pandemic
but how confident can we be in these
results
pharmaceutical company fizer announced
that their vaccine is 95
effective this result is based off of
clinical trials that have 43 000
participants
but what happens when this vaccine is
given to the broader population
well based on statistics we can conclude
that there is a 99 and 100 chance
that the fiverr vaccine has a true
efficacy rate above 90
what does that mean a 95 efficacy rate
means that one out of every 21 positive
cases in the trial are in the vaccinated
group
if we apply these odds independently to
each of the 170 positive cases in the
trial
there is a 1 in 100 chance of observing
15 or more vaccinated cases
which is the same as a 90 efficacy rate
after a long battle against covet 19 the
end is in sight
continuing to gather data is a must but
vaccine optimism is certainly not
misplaced
would you take a 95 effective vaccine
let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei